Germany produces over two million tons
of construction waste annually most of
it ends up in a landfill large trucks
transport the waste across Europe
traveling such long distances is
necessary because few places are willing
to take this rubble which often contains
toxic waste
fully grown tree needs ten years to
compensate for the co2 emissions from a
single truck traveling 100 kilometres
you can see what a huge potential there
is here for reducing co2 emissions
businessman vanta face couldn't get over
this unnecessary waste of resources the
solution to him seemed obvious why not
make new concrete out of the old within
six years he converted his family's
trucking company into a recycling yard
this is the stuff that dreams are made
of this is just normal rubble from a
building demolition first you have to
sort the material so there's no foreign
matter in it that means no wood and no
plastics and most importantly no
hazardous materials we give the stone
the material a new life I try this labor
each truck gets weighed and check to see
what's exactly in the load
a crusher breaks down the large chunks
into smaller ones a machine then
separates the rubble according to size
while removing metal and other foreign
materials
contaminated materials are reprocessed
to pee fantastic it's opened we think
you can see a bit of the future here
this system washes construction waste
that way we can recycle it normally this
material would have to be driven to a
dump site but here we can recycle up to
ninety percent of it even the water gets
reprocessed after being washed almost
all of what's left is stone and sand
valuable resources the Eco stones
produced by face and his company are
made of 100% recycled materials they can
be used in the same way as normal
concrete faces both a successful
businessman and a keen conservationist
[Music]
if we want future generations to have a
quality life - then there is no
alternative we need to reprocess our
waste wherever possible and reintroduce
it into the economy it's been proved a
thousand times that it's possible this
game you just have to produce it with
the right quality and then everyone
around the world can start doing it
these blocks made of 100% recycled
material have been set aside to build an
Information Center for visitors face
wants to teach those visitors from
around the world how to follow his
example
you